hello everyone and welcome to the other
big matchup of the American Cup uh final
semi-finals it's a Wesley so versus
Fabiano caruana Wesley who defeated uh
Sam Shanklin and Fabiana corvana who
defeated Ray Robson in the quarterfinals
uh this is the second uh or rather I
think it's the first game uh let me just
check real quickly yeah the first game
the first game of the Rapids first two
classical games ended in a draw I did go
through them in case uh something uh
amazing happened but they were two
fairly quick draws first one especially
first one was like 18 moves to draw and
the second one was okay 50 moves in the
fighting nimso Indian but still with
zero chances for uh for either side but
this one uh it's a bit a bit different
so let's check it out and see who will
face uh Hikaru Nakamura in the finals of
the American Cup so Wesley has the white
pieces and he opens with E4 we have E5
Knight to F3 Knights the C6 and Bishop
B5 the uru Lopez is on the board we have
a sex morphe's defense Bishop to A4 and
Knight to F6 with castles uh and fabigos
Ponte B5 Bishop B3 with Bishop to C5
division will be re-maneuvered to B6 or
A7 this bishop will come to B7 and then
uh Fabu will have a very nice Bishop
pair so A4 like I said in the previous
video when you see A6 B5 you push A4 no
no need the second guess that Bishop to
B7 D3 and we have castles Here pawn to
C3 and pawn to D6 all very standard
moves and nothing new being played here
Bishop to G5 pinning the Knight H6 and
here we have a trade characters captures
and Bishop to D5 now and there are a
couple of uh games that reach this
position
uh last one was actually in 1999 between
Elia Smith and John amsa where Ponte B4
was played uh but here we have Rook 8
and B8 Fabi uh doesn't go for B4 right
away he wants to prepare it and now
Wesley doesn't allow it and of course it
is now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game but now Wesley says
you will not be playing B for uh this
game sir so Bishop back to B6 and now
Knight to A3 putting pressure on that B5
pawn and here probably plays B captures
on A4 now another way to tackle this uh
threat would be maybe to go Knights the
E7 uh right away and then uh for example
Bishop captures will captures do you
temporarily give up a pawn characters
captures and captures but you always
have this very very uh unpleasant uh
situation uh here okay you can't capture
right away to regain material because
then uh well if you guys are interested
if Bishop captures just root captures
and then if root captures on B5 you have
this very unpleasant this covering
Knights the D4 attacks the queen and the
Rook but uh you know it's not that big
of a deal being down upon in that
position but instead after Knight a3b
captures an A4 was played by Fabi and
now comes Knight to C4 and now Fabi will
have to worry about this weakness for
for a very long time if not for the rest
of the game 97 Bishop captures on B7
Rook captures and now Rook captures on
A4 and now Wesley will just double up or
even triple up on the a file to go after
the A6 spawn Rook to A8 Fabi has to
prepare for that Queen E2 preparing a
rook lift Queen to E6 and now Rook F to
A1 we have Rook B to A7
uh defending the A6 pawn and now Rook
one to A3 with Knight the C6 and now
Pawn to G3 we have Ponte A5 finally
getting rid of that pawn B captures we
have Knight captures and now Knight
captures on B6 we have C characters on
V6 and now Rook to B4 and this is a very
very uh good play by Wesley if he plays
something like King to G2 which is a
move you want to play uh Fabi can just
play Knight to C6 and just trade all the
Rooks uh from the board captures
captures captures and captures and
there's really nothing more uh to be
done here it's always going to be a
better game for white because uh uh
White has one point Island this huge
Pawn chain here in Black has two point
islands and the B6 Pawn might become a
weak uh but uh I shouldn't yield more
than a draw however here Rook the B4 was
played Rook the A6 by Fabi and The Rook
the B5 now and now afabi has to worry
about the weak B6 spawn and the week
backwards the D6 spawn so Knights the C6
and now Rook characters trading off only
one pair of rocks and now only now King
to G2 this is how Wesley keeps the
tension and his chances alive because
now Fabi like I said is left with these
two weaknesses with Knight to E7 hoping
to advance the pawn to D5 and queen to
E3 stopping that but not really uh Fabi
plays Queen to A3 but he should have
gone for D5 this trades off for
everything from the board and he has
nothing to worry about if he captures
Knight captures the queen also helps out
with the B6 pawn and if Queen captures
Queen captures and Knight captures you
regain material with Knight captures and
C3 so that's uh that's how you do it but
the Fabi went for Rook day three maybe
he saw that and maybe he wanted to keep
chances alive in order to actually win
the game uh so let's see what happened
we have Pawn to C4 Knights the C8 and
now Knight the H4 going after the F5
Square so Fabi prevents at night back to
F3 King to G7 and now Ponte H4 we have
Queen to F6 and now Knights the D2 also
a very nice idea here will spawn to H5
uh messing up black spawn structure
because of G5 then you shift the Knight
to H2 and then to G4 and then black
is in a really tight situation so
instead after Queen F6 Knight the D2 was
played by Favi and now Rook to A5 uh by
Wesley uh Fabi now goes after a rook
trade here Rook the B2 declining and now
Rook to A3 we have Knights to B1 with an
attack on The Rook Rook day one and now
Knight to C3 and now the Knight has
access to D5 which will promote this
Knight into a monster Knight so Queen E6
with Knight to D5 and now Queen to G4 uh
Knight back to C3 and now Rook the A3
attacks the Knight and now Queen to D2
just defending the Knight on C3 with
Rook to A1 and now Knight to D5 Rook the
D1 now attacks uh Wesley's queen queen
to C3 and now Rook back the A1 we have
Knights the E3 attacks the queen and
queen back to D7 so how can Wesley uh
look to make some progress here well uh
he doesn't have to because the game is
already winning for him and he does that
by either playing Pawn to F4 or by
playing Rook to B6 or Rook capture some
V6 which is what was played in the game
so he starts with Rook captures on B6 we
have Knight captures on V6 now Queen
captures on A1 and now Knights the A4
Fabi uh if he wants to get a draw Queen
to A4 might be a better option but he
went Knight to A4 and now Pawn to F4 now
how do you how do you uh stop this uh
well Queen to E8 now comes F captures on
E5 and you have to capture with the pawn
if you capture with the queen then of
course you uh blunder the Knight on A4
so D captures an E5 creates the past C
Pawn for Wesley Ponte H5 uh and now
Knight to C5 going after the D3 Pawn but
it doesn't matter just H captures on G6
this is a beautiful move as you cannot
capture with the F Pawn because of Queen
to A7 check and okay you don't lose the
Knight because the Knight comes to D7
but then C5 C6 and uh it's pretty pretty
uh standard stuff so King captures and
G6 was played now comes Knight to F5 and
again if you could capture on D3 might
be might be okay for black but you
cannot defabi did this then just Queen
D1 and now the Knight is hanging and
also Queen to G4 is coming and if you
play some like Queen D7 to defend not
just Queen to G4 check King to F6 Queen
to G7 check King E6 Queen captures on H6
with the check only move Pawn to F6 and
now this beautiful queen to f8 move and
there is no defense Knight the G7 check
will end the game the black king has no
squares and you will have to part with
your with your queen so instead after
Knight to a five King the H7 was played
now comes Queen to A3 with an attack on
the knight uh Queen to C6 defending and
now Queen to A7 putting pressure on the
F7 Pawn Knight D7 and now Queen to A5 uh
we have Queen to G6 and now comes Queen
to D5 and here Wesley rushed it a little
bit a little bit with Queen to D5 Queen
to A7 Knights the H4 was the way to go
or even King to F2 but after Queen to D5
he allows Fabi one uh one move that
allows him back into the game so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
a way to pretty much uh uh you know
Force an instant draw uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
foreign
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on spotting this uh wild
idea and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Queen to H5 you
just leave the Knight hanging there
because the queen Now controls this
diagonal and you know when the queen
controls this diagonal and you have this
setup uh then you always have a
Perpetual now if Queen captures Knight
you have Queen to check and you can just
check the the white king to Infinity
Queen D1 check King F2 Queen to C2
checking E3 you have to play Queen to C1
check King has to go back because the
pawn covers uh both the D4 and F4 and
you will always have as many checks as
you want so it will be a Perpetual
however this is rapid chess they were
both very low on time uh and Knight the
F6 was played attacking the White Queen
but not just Queen captures on E5 uh we
have Knights the G for attacking the
queen and queen to D4 Queen to G5 by
Fabi with Queen to C3 now ready to
advance the past C Pawn H5 and now Pawn
to see five and this is a very very nice
idea because you might be worried about
the queen and the Knight on the king
side but the Knight on F5 covers
everything and you have nothing to worry
about so here we have Pawn to F6 now
comes Queen to beat you and now Knights
the E5 we have Pawn to C6 again
defending the pawn with a tactic if
Knight captures Queen to B7 check will
pick up the Knight so instead Queen to
G4 and now Queen to B7 with check with
King to h8 and now Queen to B8 with
check uh the problem is if you play C7
which seems like a good idea now you
actually get checkmated Queen E2
checking G1 Knight F3 check King H1 and
now Queen to F1 or H2 will be Checkmate
so instead Queen to B8 check was played
with King to H7 now comes Queen to C7
check into h8 and queen 38 with check
and he was in this position on move 63
that Fabiano Corona resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
I always get sad when people resign on
move 63 I know a lot of people get
triggered by this uh you know it's just
if you already got the 60 63 you might
as well resign and move 64. uh but you
know what do you want to do uh yeah he
resigned here as there's nothing more to
be done here once you move the king once
more once more you are very quickly
getting checkmated or you have to part
with your queen now that's the king to
G8 Knights the H6 would check wins the
black queen and well it doesn't matter
what you do you you just uh lose so yeah
after Queen 38 he resigned as there is
nothing more to be done here and it will
be Wesley so against Hikaru Nakamura in
the finals of the American Cup 2023
should be a should be a thrilling match
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and a little bit of info
about their match I would like to thank
deutron revision reptiles YouTube Mike
Wagner thought dreams and a very nice
video yesterday for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thankful for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day